allez on prend la direction du quartier
Maryse Bastié à Tours ou un déménagement
étant préparation mais pas n'importe
lequel celui de l'association active
cette entreprise emploi 25 salariés en
insertion dans la revente de vêtements
elle va bientôt rejoindre la riche
pendant plusieurs mois le temps
d'importants travaux dans ces entrepôts
Hélène chapelet
implanté depuis 33 ans cœur du quartier
Giraudeau entre tour et la riche la
boutique de vente de l'association
active est un lieu prisé de ceux qui
aiment faire de bonnes affaires sur
place on trouve notamment des vêtements
à petit prix sans cesse d'habits sont
triés ici chaque année dont 30% retourne
en boutique pour être revendu d'occasion
j'ai découvert ça grâce à une amie qui
vient régulièrement donc maintenant
c'est à mon tour de venir régulièrement
donc j'essaye de venir une fois toutes
les semaines toutes les deux semaines
parce qu'il y a toujours des petites
pépites à trouver mais Karine comme tous
les autres clients va devoir modifier
ses habitudes gardez la mi-avril la
boutique va fermer ses portes pour au
moins 9 mois de travaux le hangar qui
était une véritable passoire thermique
va être revue de fond en comble l'étage
va être aménagée de grandes ouvertures
vont être percées un chantier important
mais où les logiques de récupération et
de réemploi cher à l'association n'ont
pas été oubliés
il y a une grosse partie des matériaux
qu'on a pu récupérer sur le chantier de
démolition de l'ESSM on a récupéré les
portes on a récupéré les baies de
brassage des câbles électriques toutes
les dalles de plafond des radiateurs des
choses comme ça voilà il y a pas de
petites économies on est vraiment dans
notre logique de l'économie circulaire
en attendant la rue ouverture de ces
locaux en décembre prochain la boutique
de vente d'active va être transférée au
sein de la galerie marchande du centre
commercial de La Riche un nouvel espace
de 250 mètres carrés non loin de
l'atelier de couture qui s'y trouve déjà
depuis six mois